in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape joining us now
in the studio is dr. Christian Strasburg
on thyroid specialist from Berlin's
charity hospital hello vacuum in the
studio thank you an underactive thyroid
plant is it doesn't produce enough
homens how does this come about the most
common cause for patients suffering from
their thyroid gland not sufficiently
producing thyroid hormone is an
autoimmune disease which means that our
body's defense system which should
usually only attack foreign things like
bacteria or viruses makes a mistake and
attacks its own tissue in this case the
thyroid gland you can compare this to
the old pac-man computer game where you
have this circle with the mouth which is
chewing up little bits and one after the
other so when the immune system does
this with the thyroid gland it leads
ultimately to a very small remnants
which no longer can provide enough
hormone for the body and it typical
symptoms of an underactive thyroid gland
this weight gain what else symptoms are
there weight gain is is only a symptom
when lack of sufficient amounts of
thyroid hormone has persisted for quite
a long time since thyroid hormone is
like the spark in a car's engine for our
metabolism it will determine how much of
metabolism is going on and there for
patients with insufficient amounts of
thyroid hormone will feel more easily
cold they will prefer to turn up the
heating in a room where their colleagues
for example would prefer to open the
window at the same time bowel movements
become less frequent and the whole
metabolism is driving down so on the
long run this will also lead to weight
gain but it's not typically the first
sign okay and and how is the high power
functional thyroid gland usually treated
the treatment is to replace what's
missing so we give these patients
thyroid hormone lucky enough we have
thyroxine which is absolutely identical
to what the body makes itself so there
is no fear that there would be any side
effects if it is appropriately dosed and
on the flip side there's an overly
active thyroid gland and what are the
symptoms for those patients it's
actually also the flipside of
hypothyroid symptoms so these patients
are more nervous they are easily
sweating even at states where they have
only minor exercise for example or
stress they have more frequent bowel
movements and they are easily sweating
they prefer cold environments actually
they are the ones who open the window
when their colleagues are saying hey I'm
chilly anyway so why do you open the
window so it's quite the contour event
and then what factors lead to those
overly active thyroid glands it's
usually not pac-man is it there there
are two major causes one of them is
thyroid nodules which initially have
formed because there may have been
iodine deficiency which leads to the
formation of thyroid nodules such
thyroid nodules may be autonomous which
means they don't care how much thyroid
home on the body needs and they are
behaving in a strange way that whenever
they get hold of iodine they turn it
into ready produced thyroid hormone
regardless of how much the body would
need so these are called autonomous or
toxic nodules on centigrams they show up
in colors which we associate typically
with high temperatures so we call them
hot nodules the other cause again is the
Ottoman autoimmune disease but in this
case antibodies are not destroying the
thyroid but these antibodies are are
speeding up the hormone production by
like stepping on the accelerator of the
thyroid gland dr. schwozberg how common
is thyroid cancer thyroid cancer effects
about four hun
out of a million people per year which
if you recalculate it as 1 in 2,500
people are affected but when you want to
put this into perspective with other
cancers colon cancer for example is
eight times as frequent the interesting
third part about thyroid cancer is
females are three times more frequently
affected than males and I cannot tell
you why okay and what is the recovery
rate the recovery rate is
extraordinarily high in cancer medicine
we always look at the five-year survival
which means after the diagnosis is made
in a given patient which percentage of
these patients patients are still alive
five years later and this figure is
extraordinarily high in thyroid cancer
with 99.9 percent of all affected
patients still being alive the reason
being that there is not only surgeons
who will remove the thyroid cancer and
possibly affected lymph nodes as well
but the characteristic of thyroid tissue
that it is always trying to take up
iodine is used to destroy or burn if you
wish possible small remnants of thyroid
cancer with radioactive iodine so you
can really get rid of all the cancer
cells and therefore give the patient's a
very good chance of survival this big do
the cause of the good prognosis patients
with an enlarged thyroid glands of a
very afraid that they have cancer is
that any link between goiters and
cancers theoretically nodule or an
enlargement in the thyroid can be cancer
however for example in Germany which is
an iodine deficiency area the likelihood
of a nodule in the thyroid really being
malignant is only 1% in the united
states where there is sufficient iodine
supply by adding iodine to the flower
which is used for baking bread one out
of four nodules is malignant which only
means that they have less tissue nodules
which are benign and the result of
iodine deficiency the cancer rate per
million inhabitants is the same okay and
in talking about those enlarged thyroid
glands the goiters how do go out is
develop
they typically develop as a consequence
of iodine deficiency and it's a complex
biochemical pathway by which iodine is
actually built into so-called euro
lactones which then inhibit growth
factors and it's a complex mechanism by
which several factors then contribute to
the enlargement of the thyroid gland
which we then call a goiter what people
have to note is there is no strict
correlation between size and function so
big thyroid plants can be making too
much hormone but they can also be making
not enough format ok and if it's all
about iodine can you cure gaieties with
a good nutrition actually you can try to
prevent thyroid diseases by making sure
that you have sufficient iodine supplies
in your nutrition and this you get by
trying to consume deep-sea fish okay so
for example when you are consuming
bavarian trout's you won't help the
situation at all because these trout's
even have a little goiter themselves due
to lack of iodine but deep-sea fish is
helpful seaweed is very rich in iodine
and iodine rich nutrition can prevent
thyroid problems ok professor
schlossberg ah thanks so much for being
with us in the studio today
you